Change also in the,
in the,
in the critical arena of food journalism
when I was a kid and I started like,
you know,
reading magazines and in reading
cookbooks,
just,
you know,
for recipes and that kind of thing.
I mean,
there was um,
had Andy Burchette,
a government magazine and Mimi Sheraton
was reviewing the New York Times.
Now the,
with the Internet magazines,
you have so many outlets for food
criticism.
Um,
it's just,
it's who keeps up with it really,
you know,
and he'd other the reviews the matter,
uh,
the New York Times,
New York magazine as far as New York
goes.
And then,
you know,
the Internet is a,
it's a funny place.
Um,
you know,
there's a real difference between,
um,
Jeffrey steingarten who has traveled all
over and this has years and years and
years about writing about food than just
someone who's very enthusiastic about
food.
Um,
and,
and commenting on it because to really
criticize,
I think dishes for what they are,
it's,
you know,
if you're really criticizing it,
you should have perspective and you
should have a historical perspective.
You should have a taste per se,
you know,
a perspective,
before you really can talk about a ramen
shop,
you probably should go to Japan,
uh,
than,
you know,
just coming on,
are criticizing it because if you like
it or not,
um,
or if,
you know,
the same thing goes with Haute French
cuisine or a traditional Italian dish.
Um,
but then again,
you know,
it's like,
it's like one,
um,
you know,
the wind gates could talk about wine
till they're blue in the face,
but my dad just,
if it's good,
it's good.
He likes it,
he likes it.
So
it's a,
it's a funny situation,
but because there's the enthusiasm and
then there's the criticism.
But critics have agendas.
Um,
it doesn't matter if you're a music
critic or a movie critic or a restaurant
critic,
there is an agenda you might like,
maybe you don't like Italian food or you
think Italian food can only reach so
high on the,
um,
uh,
excitement meter,
um,
or maybe you only really want fine
dining restaurants and you don't want
casual restaurants or there's always
some kind of agenda.
And that's where the personality of of
uh,
you know,
when the writing comes out,
I had a,
have a very,
very,
very famous food writer who will go
unnamed,
said that a restaurant reviewers only
review for other restaurant critics.
I'm a little bit like restaurant
designer is only designed for the
restaurant designers and movie critics
only.
It's kind of a phenomenon.
Uh,
some people love what I do and some
people hate it.
And that's always going to be.
I'm always going to be the situation.